[Music]
well parents of students at desert oasis
high school are speaking out after the
principal jennifer bodecker was replaced
some say they're not surprised following
a rash of incidents madison kimbrough is
live this afternoon at the campus and
madison i also i understand you also
spoke briefly to the former principal
yeah i called her to just see exactly
what was going on and if she could talk
about the incident she declined to
comment however parents here at desert
oasis very different story they were
very vocal making it clear that the
blame for what's going on goes much
deeper than what they believe the
principal was able to handle
on thursday desert oasis high school
parents were alerted by email of a
leadership change on campus in the email
it did not mention principal jennifer
beaudeker's name but did say that her
role would change hands to that of mr
ian salesman as interim principal until
they find a permanent replacement mr
salzman has served as principal and
assistant principal within the district
for over 15 years
it's still unclear if principal
beaudecker was asked to step down was
removed or if she decided to leave on
her own but with the recent incidents
the general consensus from students and
parents is that more change needs to be
done i just wish we would have had a
little bit more notice than one day
maybe a meeting
a vote it's a lot to put on a principal
i mean it comes down to i think it's
i think it's a two-way street regardless
of how you look at it you know a
principal is the one that's on site
that's the face you see the face you
deal with but
you know then it's
moderation as far as the district and
how they handle things in the background
so i mean a lot of stuff's in their
control but a lot of stuff's out of
their control desert oasis has been
placed on two consecutive lockdowns in
march regarding a weapon being brought
to school and also fights on campus one
of which involved an adult parents and
teachers have voiced their concerns at
school board meetings about safety
while desert oasis has had several
incidents reported the entirety of the
district has seen an influx of violent
behavior with over 53 cases excuse me 53
hundred cases reported this year alone i
reached out to the teachers union for a
statement have not heard back yet
reporting live near desert oasis madison
kimbrough live local now